Carl jung says that everything unconscious is projected into reality.
How do you know if you are perceiving reality accurately or are just projecting?
Great.
Yeah,
well,
that's partly why I'm a pragmatist.
While there's a bunch of ways,
um,
there's a bunch of ways that you know,
pain tells you
if you make a mistake and you hurt yourself while then you're stupid.
Theory was wrong,
right?
That's what the pain says.
You're stupid theory was wrong and that's a pragmatic,
you see,
that's another indication of pragmatic theory of truth.
You lay out.
Look,
when you look at the world,
you look at the world with a set of presuppositions.
I outlined that in chapter 10 in in rules,
in 12 rules for life called be precise in your speech.
It indicates that when you look at the world,
you look at it through a value structure.
You can't help that because you're always aiming at something in the world and
you're always aiming at something you want and you're trying to get it.
And so that means that you look at the world through a value structure.
Now the question is whether or not that value structure is valid.
And that's a very complicated question.
Okay,
so how do you know if it's valid?
Number one,
you lay it out and you acted out,
you,
you implement it perceptually and then you act it out.
And if you get what you wanted,
what the theory predicted,
that's another way of thinking about it,
but wanted is a better way of thinking about it.
Then the fact that that behavioral routine and perceptual structure produced the
intended result validates it as a tool for obtaining that result.
And that's a form of truth.
Now,
it might be the only form of truth,
although I'm not convinced of that completely.
But it might be,
it's a very complicated question.
Now,
how do you know if you're stupid theory is wrong?
Okay?
A,
it fails and you're hurt.
Pain tells you,
you pragmatically,
your theory was wrong.
So that's why you should pay attention to your own pain because your suffering
is indication that you still have things to learn.
And maybe the suffering of other people is also that,
um,
maybe something unexpected or unpredictable happens when you're laying out your
plan and then the anomalous manifest itself,
the unexpected or chaos and then you get anxious.
Well,
anxiety is an indication that your plan,
your Arrow didn't fly too.
It's mark so you aimed wrong and that might mean a small error,
you know,
maybe a tiny adjustment of your bowl or it might mean you just don't know what
the hell you're doing at all and everything is lost.
And so anxiety tells you if your theory is wrong and then,
and then other people tell you that.
And that's why you want to surround yourself with other people because you
distribute your cognitive resources.
Ew,
ew.
You distribute your problems to the cognitive resources of the social group.
That's what we do when we price things,
right?
Everyone votes on the price of something because it's so difficult because the
price of something has to be established in relationship to the price of
everything else.
And that's always in flux and so it's computationally impossible problem.
And so we outsource it to the market,
which is the free cognitive decision of millions of people.
And that's how we determined price.
And so one of the things you do to make sure that you're not any stupider than
you have to be blind,
ignorant,
biased,
and all of that is you surround yourself with other people and you try to treat
them well enough so that they can tolerate you.
And then every time that you do something stupid because one of your theories
is,
is vague or incomplete or wrong or biased,
or you're willfully blind,
then they slap you on the side of the head.
They ignore you because you're boring.
They don't laugh at your jokes because they're stupid.
They,
they,
they are irritated at your auctions because you're not taking your own longterm
interests or the interests of other people into account.
And so you have pain,
you have anxiety,
you have the reward of success that that's,
that's a positive indicator that your theory is okay.
And then you have the reactions of everyone else.
And if you're clued in,
you pay attention to all of those things and you try to update your,
your order,
which is your perceptions.
You try to update your order constantly as a consequence of being humble in the
face of your errors,
which is why humility is the precondition of her learning and why it's one of
the highest moral virtues.
So.